welcome to the show only League
wrestling presents double-or-nothing
loves late we've dated 8 p.m. Eastern by
now on be or not yeah yeah that's my
name don't ok man um do me a favor you
look upside down to me just because my
phone is horizontal and I really don't
care about what your needs are
can you flip your things you're not
sideways or are we about to have an
argument I think we might have an
argument oh goody
we're off to a great start then so you
just you just want to stay sideways the
rest of this interview on my phone is
that what's happening well ideally you
would be able to make the switch and
flip it oh so you want me you want me to
do all the work you want the youngest
and fastest rising star in the history
of professional wrestling to turn his
phone over is that it ideally yes that
it you know what you know what I'll do
it I'll tell you why I'm gonna do it
it's because I'm a professional I'm a
professional
unlike jungleboy unlike darby al and
unlike Sammy Guevara on like Cody Rhodes
unlike let's be honest here pretty much
everybody on the ALW roster I am one of
the only professionals and that's why
I'm the face of the company it's because
I'm one of the only people that could
properly represent aew so let's go on
Chatty Cathy what questions you got for
me today
I appreciate you everybody does
let's go where we go all right well
we'll start off with your last night's
actions that dynamite against Marcos
done one still undefeated
yep they all undefeated yep the winning
streak is 13 I believe now absolutely I
know it could be 10 it could be 11
singles wins but I'll take 13 if you
want to say 13 I had no problem with
that um no no it was opened up I enjoyed
myself a good red glass I earned it I
had myself a cigar as well and yeah I
mean it was a hard-earned victory I
think anybody who understands
professional wrestling anybody can win
any time I was not trying to look past
Marco stunts he's no
I'm just I'm just nothing to you guys
he's horrible he's a small child I knew
I was going to win I played with my food
for a little bit and did I get in
trouble for about 0.2 seconds maybe I
don't know but you know a little kid he
got excited he went through a dive I
knocked him out and then I had some fun
the ring tapped now with the salt of the
earth
armbar which just so happens to be the
most dangerous technical maneuver and
all professional wrestling and yep gotta
got the old W Jim Ross good old jr.
wasn't too happy about it
good old fat prick Tony Schiavone he was
too happy about it and neither was
Excalibur with a shitty smelly Dukey
looking mask that fake-ass Lucha Libre
star but I don't care if you're happy
about it or if you're not happy about it
cuz at the end of day I keep winning I'm
undefeated if you're mad about it
beat me I'm begging I am literally I'm
think somebody please beat me please
shut me up I'm waiting for it Harry
Harry I'm waiting for it I'm getting
bored I'm bored I think what people took
issue with wasn't the match itself water
win it was your actions afterwards when
you find smart go stun with your diamond
ring I can you explain why you decided
to do that you ever hear the story of
the sacrificial lamb Harris I have
actually there you go boom it's that's
it here's the thing that a lot of people
in our industry don't seem to understand
wrestling is half the battle maybe a
quarter of the battle may be accorded
the battle what's really important is
getting your opponent's head jungleboy
he's a child he's literally a child I'm
a grown-ass man I might be 24 but I'm a
grown-ass man both physically and
mentally when I hit his friend she have
any idea what that does to his insides
he's not gonna be able to be calculated
on Saturday now Harris now the only
thing he's gonna be worried about is
beating me up he's not gonna be worried
about getting the ring which is the most
important part that's why we're here
buddy we're here to move up in the ranks
we're here to make a lot of money and
we're here to get famous get in get out
I don't care about this business I care
about making money and strategically me
making Marco kiss the dynamite diamond
ring 40
five thousand dollars by the way was a
smart strategic move you're facing
jungle boy this Saturday I'm double or
nothing yes
you've already defeat a jungle boy twice
at atw what was the reasoning behind
fighting him a third time considering
you don't really have anything left to
prove against Norway well certainly
wasn't up to me that was the matchmakers
um which I hate to say it but I think
you and I both know that a certain
individual is an EVP in that company and
I'm not quite sure he's a big old fan of
mine and let's face it jungle boy
whether I want to admit it or not is an
incredible competitor that man has so
much potential
he truly does he has so much potential
he's got potential and in all of our
matches whenever he'd been to wring
together he's one of the only people on
a roster who even came remotely close to
beating me do I think this decision was
intentionally made because the powers
that be don't like the fact that I'm
Jeff is undefeated yeah duck you'd have
to be blind not to see that but it
doesn't matter cuz I'm still gonna get
the win because I'm a superior wrestler
and that's what I'm going to do I'm
going to out wrestle jungle boy there
are a lot of people and it's laughable
to me that I'll see on the Internet
they'll go man mjf he's such a great
talker but he's such a jerk he's he's
not he's not trying out there he's not
he's not wrestling as hard as wrestling
guys why work hardest when he can work
smart are you guys aware and you can
look up my matches when I was on the
independent scene I could do moonsault
450s Fosbury flops you name it oh I
could do all of it then I realized
something was I doing that to get the
win or was I doing that to try to
impress people Harris which one do you
think it was the earlier in the ladder
there earlier that's right
I was I was doing it I was doing it took
Oh God see what happened he made me flip
my throwing hands that's why we got he I
was doing it because I thought it was
helping me try to win but deep down what
it really was is I was trying to impress
the marks and then once I realized that
it had no benefit to me I stopped I
almost superior athlete to everybody in
the aew locker that includes your pack
your Phoenix's your orange Cassidy's I'm
a freak athlete but me doing a cool
little flipping you do now flip the a
isn't gonna get me the winners purse and
that's why I'm going to be jungle boy
I'm going to out Tekken I'm going to
have less limb I'm going to out athlete
him and I'm going to pin him or submit
him and that's just what its gonna be at
the end of the day a double or nothing
is he gonna put up a great fight
probably I hope he does cuz like I said
I'm getting bored
I'm getting very very bored I just want
some competition Harry give me something
hopefully jungle boy is not competition
so it sounds like you're saying that
only a portion of your potential has
been shown from you would you agree with
that absolutely and here's the thing
when there comes a time where I'm going
to need to break out something supremely
acrobatic to help me win by all means
I'll do that because I will do whatever
it takes to get the W but I haven't had
to do that so why would I why would I
put my body in harm's way let's talk
about putting our bodies and harm way
real quick did you see what happened to
Ray Phoenix last night ooh let me do a
neat little springboard off the top rope
that'll get the fans going great bud now
you're gonna need a hip replacement at
35 congratulations congratulations it's
stupid I'm going to bring my opponents
down to the mat and I'm going to grind
them out I am going to grind them out
and I'm going to wear them out because
that is a smart thing to do in the UFC
but seriously in the UFC have you ever
seen a top fighter climb to the top of
the cage and go for a moonsault to
finish off their opponent no it's
illegal in the UC yeah yeah well first
of all no oh hi Harry so let's let's
just let's just be logical here let's
just be logical here and that's it
that's what my opponent jungleboy loves
to do he loves the flip flop and fly and
impress people go ahead man
kill yourself go out there and murder
yourself for these fans that don't pay
you by the way you know who pays me Tony
Khan and guess what he don't pay me by
the
you don't pay me to flip he pays me to
professionally wrestle you mentioned ray
Phoenix earlier a place in the casino
ladder match this Saturday and double or
nothing hopefully and that would be a
great match are you disappointed at all
that you aren't part of that match
obviously the winner does get a shot at
bay udemy Championship absolutely not
I'll tell you why I'm not disappointed
um I'm a star I'm a top guy in our
company I'm the face of this company
everybody's fully aware that I'm going
to be the person that will be leading a
each of you into the next decade perhaps
millennia it's just everybody knows that
nobody nobody wants to say it out loud
but everybody internally like oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm Jeff's the guy you know put me
in a match with eight other dudes where
I'm just trying to stand around my thumb
and my like no obviously if I'm Tony
Khan I want to put mjf in a singles
match because that's gonna get of you
guys it's really that simple and I get
it I get it I'm a prizefighter I
understand what my job is my job's to
boost ratings I'm one of the only guys
in our roster who does it so yeah it
makes sense to put me in a singles match
um I don't know if I'll ever be ready to
give fat disgusting marks a platform to
be able to talk to me but out of the
kindness of my heart because I am so
salt of the earth Harry I'll do it just
for you just for you thank you I
appreciate that all right first question
what inspired you to become a pro
wrestler me next question okay how are
you going to celebrate your win after
double or nothing again I'm gonna pop me
a bottle of red wine I'm gonna sip on it
nice and slow probably watch some
mid-south wrestling and call it a night
mid-south I like it why is Burberry your
starfish choice and not another brand
Burberry is by far the most important
brand in the world Burberry is the
standpoint of excellence it's the
standard of excellence if you do not own
a
piece of Burberry where you're poor and
that is why I rock a Burberry scart it's
the best okay what profession which you
have pursued if it wasn't wrestling you
know I'd love to stand back here and
goes stand up acting whatever but but in
all reality God put me on the screener
to be a professional wrestler that's why
I was born that's why I was placed here
that's what I was meant to do that's
what I'm supposed to do and it's very
obvious so I don't I could look into
this camera and say and say yes I would
love to do movies I would love to do TV
music whatever because I'm so
multi-talented it's literally nothing I
can't do
but realistically I understand why I was
placed here and it wants to be the
greatest world champion in the history
of our great sport that is pro wrestling
all right what do you like to do in your
off time workout bang rats
it's about it being honest here yeah
absolutely
I like redheads what do you like
redheads Harry do I like redheads what I
stutter
do you like redheads Harry I don't mind
all right
what is it you got a problem redheads no
what you what are you into man tell the
world what you're into
you know redheads blonde I don't judge
based on your right hand your left hand
all right buddy what's the next question
moving right along what's your favorite
mass that you were part of and one you
weren't part of I'm just in my favorite
Maps I was a part of was when I defeated
the American Nightmare of Cody Rhodes um
my favorite match I wasn't a part of was
MJ f versus Jung the boy a double or
nothing because it hasn't happened yet
but I can assure you it's gonna be a
barn burner cuz I'm gonna be in the
match okay what about our match that you
were not a part of what's your favorite
I really don't watch
other people if I'm gonna watch
wrestling it's gonna be me watching some
some old-school 80s we're talking
world-class mid-south aw a global
someone like the the og NWA TNA stuff's
pretty solid but yeah I mean nobody
really does it for me in my generation
outside of me the only person who I
could like genuinely watch and enjoy
outside of me maybe maybe Jericho I mean
you gotta admire that guy
the man's a living legend but I mean
outside of me and Chris who's really
worth watching
you know oh well in fairness we have
seen you on national TV watching these
dynamite episodes you are betting with
Shawn Spears now hold on a second
there's watching and then there's
betting I'm not watching for joinings or
entertainment I'm watching to make money
there's a very big difference
I can literally bet on a game of lose or
a game what's that weird shitty sport in
the open the Winter Olympics where
people just push a rock I could
technically I can let me not like it
doesn't mean I'm interested in it that
just means I'm trying to make some money
are you in the red he's full of [ __ ] I
saw the sign he had on TV and look Shawn
I know you're listening because lord
knows everybody is on our roster because
everybody looks up to me I don't owe you
money
okay we're dead even right now
legitimately we are dead even in betting
I'm not up he's not up I'm not happy
about that fact that's just that's
that's what's up I saw what he said MJ
F's money but he owes me something I
don't know anything Shawn a my money no
yeah you got that part right
that's for damn sure so where are you
guys typically betting on when you're
watching these matches obviously who
comes out the winter grass that's that's
the most obvious one yeah we also get
the technical stuff this person might
get three holds on brother who's gonna
throw the most chops um who's gonna
who's gonna scream shut up because let's
face it that's kind of some people's go
twos cuz they're not exactly creative
there's certain things we'll bet on man
you know I don't need to get into all of
it with you Harry if we're being
completely honest the fact I'm even on
this show right now you should just be
thanking your lucky stars I'm thankful
every day yeah you know what's the
greatest moment of your career I'm again
I'm gonna have to say with all due
respect and at the end of the day with
our like to admit it or not the guy is
my mentor don't like him don't like in
them all but the moment that I be Cody
Rose there's no certainly a moment that
sent me in stone as a main eventer I
think that's brutally obvious because
I'm not a not a fan of them but you
can't look around and tell me that Cody
Rhodes isn't at the pinnacle of our
industry right now along with MJ uh so
what was your reaction when he did that
moonsault backwards off the case
Oh total market your mark he got lucky
the fact that look Wardlow is a little
out of it when he stole my dynamite
diamond ring and cheated and punched him
with it uh so he got lucky but man let
me climb up this cage and do a moon er
yeah your mind but whatever man
that's how badly he wanted to get his
hands on me and guess what he did guess
what he you know you win was the
moonsault absolutely incredible yeah you
know what else is incredible though
winning you mentioned Wardlow we've seen
him a couple times in the ring you know
we're gonna start seeing it more often
um here's the thing Wardlow at the end
of the day my bodyguard however the guys
has all the potential in the world to
become this juggernaut of our industry
and when I say juggernaut I don't use
that word lightly because that's what he
is he's um he's a massive beast of a man
and I think he has an insane future
ahead of him right now however his job
is to carry my bags take my ring off or
put it on my pinky and beat people up
that I tell them to beat up and that's
probably
his job the rest of his career until I
feel I'm totally ready to let him loose
and one 121 of these days I will I mean
the the thing that people don't seem to
understand is is I have a great
relationship with my boy war dog right
but I'm I'm helping him I'm mentoring
this kid because at the end of the day
he might be older than me but he's he's
still learning on the job and he needs
me right and in a certain way
I need him a little bit we're a tag team
we are a partnership and I love him
dearly um every time you see him on your
TV set he is absolutely brutalizing
people and I'm I'm sure it's gonna be
like that for years and years and years
to come
what was the go-to song for you and the
acafellas to perform in high school oh
that's easy
so come around Christmastime excuse me
we sang
um this is BCAAs and creatine what do
you know about that very I can tell
probably nothing around Christmastime
silent night was a big hit big hit I'm
trying to think of I mean we did it yet
we did a Beatles melt medley one time
t-pain song we did a lady gaga song I
mean we we were we were good like really
good like to the point where we got hit
up by America's Got Talent obviously at
that point I did not feel I wanted to be
on TV until I was professional wrestling
so I declined out the a spar group since
I was the manager no big deal not not
mean to like drop that on everybody but
I was I was also an all-state Inquirer
in an all-state middle linebacker no big
deal only person in the history of my
high school to do that
I also broke the tackling record for a
season at a hundred and ten tackles and
if you don't believe me
type in max Freedman football huddle
click on it and you can watch every
single tackle I made my senior year
what's the funniest locker
memory you have as part of the football
team um you know there weren't a lot of
fun ones just because I I'm I'm a leader
I can't help that I'm I'm a big-time
leader I'm a lion in that sense and if
people get out of line you know I let
him know and if people weren't up to par
with what they needed to be play for
play I let them know as well there was
no room for weakness in my locker room
that's what kind of makes me sick about
aew there are so many guys I'd like to
bring into a corner and go like hey get
in shape fix your teeth take a shower
but it's not the respectful thing to do
and I'm a professional respectful guy
all right this question is just why are
you the way that you are um I have two
amazing parents they never got separated
they're still together to this day I
have two awesome sisters and yeah I mean
my family is great my life's been great
I was great at sports um never drank or
drugged outside of my nice wine and uh
yeah I mean all around I'm just an
absolute role model for literally
everyone which is why respect for Baker
as well she's definitely coming into her
own she's a great role model - yes yeah
what did you have for lunch or what are
you going to have for lunch
um I ate myself an egg chicken cheese
wrap that's the only thing I've eaten
I'm fasting a little bit before this
pay-per-view because I want to look good
and I continue to look good and one of
the only people on our TV show that
looks like the wrestler so I need to
keep that up that's nice did you make it
yourself but if you order it I did not I
don't make a bun stop yes i order it you
[ __ ] nuts are you aware that there's
an IG account for your scarf at and jaea
underscore scarf I am aware I am aware
of that Twitter handle I'm aware of that
person's tweets um he's doing one hell
of a job here Merlin is what's that
is it your burner I honestly I wish it
was but I don't do that because unlike
everybody else in my industry
I'm not complete
insane and needing to get even more of
my [ __ ] out there I don't care for that
here's what I do on Twitter by three
initials
I read everybody talking about how great
I am I go to bed that's it I do not have
a burner account however the MGF scarf
Twitter accounts very solid big fan big
fan okay and also an MJ have dynamite
diamond ring account as well so I'll get
to it yeah
I'm sure MJ underscore scarf is really
gonna appreciate that so there we go
you are the mark what's the worst bad
beat you've ever had when bedding next
okay
what's been your favorite City dynamite
has been to none next gross I just want
to go to Long Island already brutal have
you seen that pitch perfect and if so
how accurate is no no no I've not seen
naughty
no I have not no okay but you talked
about Long Island and how excited you
are to get back there what's your
favorite course Long Island Oh what
can't you do in Long Island Long Island
has the best food the best women the
best bars the best gyms it's it's
literally it's it's Valhalla it's heaven
it's literally it's heaven on earth and
if you live anywhere else you're a
you're a buffoon you're an absolute goof
and that's just my take on it
respectfully respectfully Harry I'm it
just says you're the most important
person to ever live agree I know
yeah I'm I'm fully aware of that alright
last question for you this afternoon
double or nothing against jungle boy
8:00 p.m. Eastern order on your live if
you haven't already what's gonna be the
outcome what's gonna happen during the
match take us through what your strategy
is um I'm not gonna give you my strategy
because that would that would be wildly
stupid and people who do that on these
interviews are wildly stupid what I will
tell you is I'm going to win
um and the thing I will leave you with
is the ends justify the means and that's
that get the job done get the job done
and that's what I'm gonna do a double or
nothing I'm gonna get the job done this
Saturday double or nothing and Jeff
against jungle boy 8:00 p.m. Eastern on
be our live order if you haven't already
and Jeff thank you so much for joining
us appreciate you taking the time I
appreciate you flipping your phone I
know that was tough
yeah I'm not a I'm not a fan of what
occurred here and before I hang up the
phone I do want you to know I will be
having a conversation with your boss
talk to you never